how's it going resumes parent okay so
oculus rift just had a virtual reality
jam which basically led to a lot of
developers made their own kind of tech
demos of some really cool ideas but
they're kind of short and kind of for my
taste too short for a video so I decided
I'm gonna try out a couple of them and
and that will make a video so you
brothers aren't like be really I'm sorry
sure yeah you're welcome
anyway should be fun hell yeah I oh this
is so cool all right let's go whoa oh
funk of a terrible dragon oh oh my god
I'm a genius dragon oh oh there's a
castle whoo yeah bro
okay dun dun there's a dragon oh that's
right [ __ ] oh they're shooting at me
stop and shoot at me yeah what you gonna
do about it I'm a [ __ ] drag out [ __ ]
land on him dant and Anna rant and error
and and arrrrr
no don't-don't-don't under oh hello sir
how's your gender way not so good while
I'm eating what nothing I didn't eat it
I killed him that's what I did this is
so amazing all right
Dredd halls at it huh good thing I don't
have a controller I have one I just
don't want to plug it locked in what was
that oh cool ow
what that [ __ ] was that this is legit
I like this all right
ha ha ha hey what am i doin Nene hello
let's look at the mat Jesus Christ
whatever this is stupid microphone
trynna what the [ __ ] that is one sexy
alien all right that's what you sound
like
aliens I think we can brother gonna run
overheat oh [ __ ] man ah
what the [ __ ] hello oh okay
we're not gonna we're not even gonna
bother with that [ __ ] we're not even
gonna bother with [ __ ] whoa what the
[ __ ] hey man you don't have a dick
you're not so tough now okay you're
pretty tough I'm going on here I don't
like this is it spooking me out man I
don't like hearing stuff okay we made it
I have so much goosebumps it's [ __ ]
insane this is so creepy
Oh jack bloody what the hell are you
guys you guys I really like each other
huh what the [ __ ] Oh No milk milk
what
what what what hey [ __ ] you man
Oh chef what the [ __ ] are you okay here
we go whoa whoa what this okay we swings
does your is my game whoa-ha-ha
yeah yeah
I'm going to chop you up into little
pieces and cook you like butter Romy's
and then I must [ __ ] you out like a box
of sandals get the gum exams put up him
in a [ __ ] crazy
Oh Oh show me what you got
boom boom stop in the bench oh whoa Oh
I collect away my or Milan my time stop
that [ __ ] City
Oh No Swedish style [ __ ] is that
done you got ha one [ __ ] buff holy
[ __ ] like my nipples oh my god
I'm stabbing your [ __ ] ah are you
okay I'm sorry Matt dude I'm sorry you
got a not your night is creeping me out
man
Oh dad look okay Oh cut of youth I'm a
cut-up I'm gonna cut you I'll cut you
I'm a cut
yeah yeah yeah what you go
oh [ __ ] these people are crazy chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop doctor Oh
God does it it does inside I'm a custard
you have a family is that right well let
it yeah you like that don't you say on a
spray lick it look at Chama wow it's too
late [ __ ]
all right let's get the baddies it's so
cool looking out of the arena like this
feels amazing it looks like I might
sword up my ass or something I'll [ __ ]
my sword is sucking my ass I hate when
that happens
oh my god rocket bring it bring it
blockage what well that's an awesome
blockage later new kind of your nipples
fatality how could it happen to me I'm a
mom it whoa
oh no I mean fighting that guy all right
bring it [ __ ] I'm back hi
Oh
my arm ah I press I hope that gives you
a good I've got a good idea of what's to
come with the virtual reality I'm not
getting paid for anything about this by
the way there's a ton of more minigames
like this so if you want me to play more
I'll be happy to do so let me know and
leave it like it helps me out a lot
hit subscribe to come birth today I'll
see you in the next month stay awesome
guys love you doctor I'm not gonna make
out with you I told you make out with
you not cool right there so you just
have to get over it get another
girlfriend
I mean boyfriend